got a story now about a mid-air scare
that none of us would ever want to face
a passenger without any flight
experience landed a plane yesterday
after the pilot suffered a medical
emergency just take a listen to the
dramatic audio between that passenger
and air traffic control
i've got a serious situation here about
pilots
no idea
roger what's your position
i have no idea
in front of me and i have no idea
maintain wings level and uh just try to
follow the coast either north or
southbound we're trying to locate you
just continue the slow descent until you
get to 5 000 feet and just continue
south or continue northbound over the
beach and we'll get you further
instructions get you to toward an
airport
controllers then guided the passenger
through landing procedures for that
cessna aircraft and the good news is he
nailed the landing no word on his name
or the condition of the pilot who
suffered that emergency but uh as for
the fill-in pilot he is one chill dude
i'll say i'll say i love the air traffic
control saying just continue your
descent how do you even do that that's
what i'm saying then you see the air
traffic controller nate and he's giving
instructions from a picture right of the
dashboard yeah i wouldn't be listening
thinking that's not enough information
you got to tell me more please
i have no idea how to follow this
airplane wow good teaching from air
traffic control and good calm under
pressure performance from that fill-in
pilot i'd love to know his name but
don't you think you could do that if if
you're terrified and you know that your
life depends on it wouldn't you just
follow every single instruction yeah no
matter how scared you are down to the
detail i would like to think